es una retirada con consecuencias
potencialmente importantes las tropas
rusas habrían comenzado a abandonar la
ciudad de gerson en el sur de Ucrania la
única capital capturada por Moscú desde
su ofensiva de marzo las unidades del
contingente de tropas rusas se está
moviendo hacia las posesiones
establecidas en la orilla izquierda del
Río néeper en las últimas semanas
imágenes de satélite e informes han
mostrado que los rusos estuvieron
abriendo líneas de trincheras en la
orilla izquierda del Río en previsión de
este movimiento lo que indica que se
trata de una decisión tomada desde hace
tiempo muscula justificado por
dificultades en el mantenimiento de las
líneas de suministro para sus tropas
pero kiev declaró que el repliegue se
debe a la combatividad de los ucranianos
hoy tenemos buenas noticias del sur el
número de banderas ucranianas que
regresan a sus lugares en el marco de la
operación de defensa en curso se cuenta
ya por decenas 41 territorios han sido
liberados
según los observadores una retirada
completa podría llevar varias semanas
Moscú no ha facilitado ninguna
información mientras que kiefa advertido
que cualquier anuncio de Rusia al
respecto debería tomarse con cautela en
los próximos días se espera que las
tropas ucranianas sigan acercándose a la
ciudad de gerson aunque los analistas
afirman que es poco probable que
intenten avanzar más hacia el este los
ucranianos por su parte advirtieron que
Rusia podría lanzar ataques de
artillería contra la ciudad desde sus
posiciones en la orilla oriental de Río
según los analistas la reconquista de
gerson la reforzaría la convicción de
kiev de que puede derrotar a Rusia para
Moscú en cambio la pérdida de gerson
podría suponer el revés muy importante
desde que las fuerzas rusas fueron
expulsadas de las afueras de kiev en
marzo